bang-bang I'm here with Adam Draper
thank you so much for coming
bang bang bang bang yes sir not everyone
bang bang oh just like banner pay
attention I'm nervous
sci-fi sigh I'm I'm here with palm I'd
rather be called Adam Draper is cooler
name then pop Arkansas what up on the
live stream alright so here we go ready
that's a good use okay continue what's
your background
okay my back everyone knows you as the
man who wears their orange pants but
you're actually way more substance i
under Neath those pants that sounds
weird this is so refreshing I gotta say
thank you for having me on this I've
been you know up and down talking to
endowments and all these places that you
serious people where you lookin ties
yeah and this is the energy you guys you
guys have good energy yeah that's fine
okay ah my background is okay so in
between high school and college I play
them going way back I played tennis in
Australia are you good
I was good I mean I was trying to go pro
and then I yeah yeah and then I would
play you of your bad side ego and then I
ended up at UCLA and I was an English
major and I didn't know what I wanted to
do and then I in basically I was forced
in an English major I didn't have
credits and units towards that education
we talked about education yeah I'm
waiting for somebody has a Twitter major
oh my gosh Twitter major would be so
valued that's what people should write
on the resumes yeah
that would be brilliant and then so my
background was I started a company it
was called expert financial with a guy
named Thomas Foley and we were a
secondary market for private securities
actually at the same time Barry Silbert
who's at DC gee I don't know if he's
been on this he feel he is not gonna
bond okay I I just saw him yesterday and
he he's great and he was starting he was
working at second mark he started second
market and we were sort of competitive
in this secondary market for private
security space and
I went on and after about four and a
half years of running expert financial
we it did end up selling to a company
called ven evade renovate was bought by
a company called King oh my god what was
it called Keystone Keystone
Keystone was bought by companies
recently for experts 80s that we had so
technically came full circle and but
because I invested in coinbase so you
know the value chain works I after
expert financial I realized that the I
had a lot of fun mentoring startups and
not doing what I did in making mistakes
I made a lot of mistakes what was the
biggest mistake you made we start a
company I think I have in a regulated
space so we were a broker-dealer we were
we had to be a broker-dealer to be able
to transact securities the biggest
mistake that we made was I using the SEC
as a product manager so like having
their input on like how it should be
working yeah so that it is like
regulated and secure rather than just if
I were to go back and do it I would not
be paid and I would try to facilitate it
a lot of transactions of secondary so I
would go through the process Paul Graham
says do things that don't that don't
scale I same system I would go through
the that system once and then I'd do it
again
and then you use technology to enhance
the process you don't start with the
technology yep
and so that I would say you should talk
to a lot of crypto people there got a
little backwards there yeah well I mean
like yes yeah that is a key thing you
you need to understand who your
customers yeah so like one of the lead
things when people reach out cold to me
in an email they say like what they do
or they lead with the worst was in 2017
2018 when they were leading with how
much money they had oh yeah yeah it was
like oh I see oh only 1 million left
raised 18 or whatever and it's like I
don't even know what you do and you've
been writing for three centons oh my
I'll take it one step further it was
like people would show up and they'd
send you
think about hey we have 27,000 people
are telegram channels yeah like that's
okay congratulations that's a like
that's a metric by the way what do you
do and so what I ask them now is I say
well I say well who's your customer yep
these at the end of the day like if I
actually find that most startups most
crypto or otherwise don't actually know
who the end customer is yeah and most of
the time it's not who you think it is
and so that ends up being a very
intuitive question to see how far along
they are in the process if they can
succinctly tell me this is two of my
customers this is the demographic and
this is how much money we make off of
them you're further along than almost
anyone absolutely would it actually the
company would you do next so I founded
what was the first ever crowdfunding
website for equity really it was called
boost funder okay okay and then what I
realized was like I'm going deeper than
I probably know how long this goes be I
could be I mean we might go four hours
oh good perfect kind of the bathroom but
I'll still be here uh the so I founded
boost funder and it was basically my way
of going okay
the SEC regulators they only care if
you're actually making money yep so like
if you're taking a fee they think that
the greed is involved so I was like I'm
not gonna take a fee I'm gonna match
investors and entrepreneurs online and
so what I launched it but I realized
that there was a discrepancy between
what an investor needs to invest and
what an entrepreneur the level B
entrepreneur thinks they are at to get
investment and so I was like you know
what the best way to solve this is
actually offline okay and and so that
led to boost which founded as an
accelerator but now is proceed fund
focused on investing in sci-fi
technologies okay before we get to boost
let's talk about coinbase okay cuz you
invested I think you were the first
investor I yes I was the first investor
they did go through YC though okay so
technically was it describe what your
experience with Bitcoin crypto etc was
pre coinbase let's talk about the
Colombian vestment okay that part is a
good question because it's very short I
had no previous experience individual
Bitcoin crises so they I got a list of
companies that sent to me and I read
through all the descriptions and one of
them said marketplace for digital
currencies and I said I do not know what
that is what is a digital currency what
does I don't know what that is um and so
I called emailed Brian Armstrong at
coinbase
founder CEO yeah founder CEO and I said
and I wrote this email sort of making
myself sound better than I was and I've
invested in a couple companies before
coinbase I and I said those in the email
and then I said do you want to meet for
coffee I met it we did we met at a place
called Red Rock which is in Mountain
View I highly recommend it it's a good
coffee place it's got good good coffee
and then I he said that like he's
sponsored by right but I actually I like
to thank them because I've written I've
invested in three companies who I met at
Red Rock who total market cap today are
worth like 10 billion dollars or
something so like so so Jeff will become
only go to Red Rock collective valuation
um and Brian said one thing and he said
a lot of things about his background
I've sort of an emerging theory about
entrepreneurs and it's like rational
people doing irrational things or
irrational people doing rational things
also works but the but Brian Armstrong
he was coming he left Airbnb in the at
that point it was a billion dollar
company he had been he was one of the
first hundred employees um and he had
started two companies previously so like
this founder looks on paper very like
rational and when I was talking to him
he was very rational but what he said to
me was at some point the world is going
to be on one financial infrastructure
and the concept of that means all of the
countries have to have a connected
financial infrastructure
which is an insane concept and he's
saying Bitcoin at that time Bitcoin is
gonna be that financial infrastructure
and he was referring to himself and
saying what coinbase is is the gateway
it would be the Netscape to the browser
to the Internet and I just started to
obsess over this concept of a connected
financial infrastructure and so what I
did was I did diligence and I started
talking to other people in the Bitcoin
world he referred me to a couple people
and I talked to a couple more people who
were the people he talked to you so I
talked to someone who it was a founder
at his name is Laurent who was at it was
a app search engine at the time called
quick see he was the CTO and then I
talked to Bill bard aiight who runs out
now I talked to I talked to a it was a
bunch of people who are now like you
know if thought leaders in the space
actually and the in the overarching
consensus that I felt was this is the
most dynamic community of people like
whether or not the technology is there
like these are these are like some of
the most dynamic people smartest I've
done it by dynamic I mean like smartest
but also like passionate about changing
the world and little crazy like all of
them are a little crazy but they all
seem they know these backgrounds like my
first experiences with Bitcoin were not
drug deals or anything like that
it was it was literally like people with
15 years of experience in finance trying
to buy coffee with Bitcoin at Red Rock
yeah trying to buy a copy of the red
book and I read rock I need to go there
again I need to start having my meetings
there album but we'll buy the building
at some point and just be like I have
element meetings it'll be a co-working
space we'll do it together
that's fine the answer that was my sort
of kumis ind up investing because of the
dynamic community as well as this just
you know rational person been doing
unravel things irrational things yeah so
Kanye who had is a legend on Twitter at
this point says Tom be a genius you know
that isn't crazy
menders development of what you're
describing that fits that's it so they
fit the yeah it's like they're they are
crazy don't even write all of them are
crazy yep but they come off as
semi-rational yeah Elon is like probably
the perfect example well he actually if
you sit down and you listen to him talk
you're like you know what I could see
how he could get to an entire
conversation and say everything he just
said with a straight face and no one
think he's crazy but do you understand
the guy's just said they're gonna go to
Mars that's see that's one time back
like the like you know the person
exactly he wants perfect example but he
lines a perfect example where it's like
on paper he sold PayPal he like you know
has this background of building and
delivering and then he says oh we're
going to Mars yeah yeah it was a perfect
exam
so as you're building boost let's go
through how you actually well what does
boost mean by the way first of all so
boost means like be oo st but not boost
mobile like the phone carrier that's so
funny we used to get a lot of overlap of
people being really oh you work at Boost
Mobile early early on in the like people
would like to tap me on the shoulder and
be like oh you work at this boy and
iPhone doesn't work boot boost Wireless
so boost is a community of people we
have housing and office space ok in
downtown San Mateo and so in the Bay
Area in Silicon Valley and we bring
people from all over the world working
in highly technical industries like
crypto and virtual reality and oceans
and space and we bring them and it's
almost like a home base for companies
and startups to be able to connect to
Silicon Valley ok so it's almost like so
we can live there work there our
accelerator program we run once a year
and the companies come in for three
months and they live in the housing work
in the office space we're running a
program right now with 20 startups 9
crypto fantastic stuff and the yeah and
so that it like boosts what we what I
feel is that being for venture capital
being
the connection to the entrepreneur at
the earliest stage closest to the idea
is the most powerful position to be and
so what we do is try to provide sort of
a safe spot a home base for those people
to be able to really innovate in the Bay
Area while also being able to connect to
a network in Silicon Valley got it ye
set up in San Mateo rather than San
Francisco for those they don't know San
Mateo is outside of the city you think
of it that way and San Francisco is a
city so one reason would be that we have
the housing and office space there the
other reason that's a good reason yeah
yeah that's where the building is where
the building is and since we've moved in
like I've seen a whole cultural shift
from San Mateo being a very sleepy town
to listening in at coffee shops and
deals are being done and that's like it
was a seismic shift over the last seven
years of watching these different people
come in and just change the world and
it's been fantastic to watch YouTube
found in San Mateo admob San Mateo so
Google only buys things that are in
started and CEMA so that's like two
things now right let's go to Red Rock
and then if you started amitab you
should it's got a SIA deep roots root
rooted DNA but it also has boost and
we're and now we back 300 startups all
right so you guys are accelerating
companies and you were also investing in
companies that don't go through the
accelerator as well correct so we
started as an accelerator and I found
that to be the best way to sort of read
to solve this problem of getting to know
the entrepreneur earliest and then we
verticalized in to Bitcoin and virtual
reality and then as we you know
developed our very brand and we started
to understand that there were companies
outside the accelerator who wouldn't
join who are third time founders who you
know are in the crypto space or the
virtual reality space we wanted to be
able to invest in great people and so
being able to write a 250 to 500
thousand dollar check allows us to do
that also and you're trying to invest as
early as possible always we drug be
first check more than anything we want
to make the
decision for ourselves we always like to
just say like we're the first decision
one of them we say first check but it
writ like there could be someone else in
and like we we just want to actively
make the decision for ourselves whether
or not we are investing got it let's go
to all the non crypto stuff first
sure VR I'm strong opinions on crypto
also I know you do that's are my savings
to the end when you're tired oh yeah VR
AR ocean space like you guys are going
for all these different verticals let's
start with VR na our first okay why are
you excited I think it's super important
that we start with VR AR first okay okay
I hear let me stop you for a second
we're gonna start with the VRA are the
so Adam has taken over the PI so I last
week was this week is actually GDC which
is the gaming Developers Conference and
tons of it's VR now like almost like a
huge segment of this conference that's
one of the biggest gaming conferences in
the world has taken over in is virtual
reality describe the difference between
virtual reality and augmented reality
for people they don't know okay so
virtual reality is I am enclosing myself
in a new world of digital reporters you
put goggles on
you put full goggles on and you don't
see beyond your goggles it could be you
could be in space you could be in Athens
Greece like 100% percent artificial or
synthetic world yeah like that synthetic
world I deal with synthetic world I just
made it up yeah augment and so augmented
reality is overlaying data on our real
world I would say like if you played the
Pokemon game Niantic they overall a
little pokemons on your phone which is
overlaid on the world I would actually
argue that the first major augmented
reality platform is actually audio so
it's Alexa or air pods or because it's
overlaying data on our world it's just
not visual virtual reality is very very
visual it's very difficult to do like a
radio version of virtual reality because
it's fully immersive it is you are being
teleported to this other place dude when
Apple figures out the battery
from the air pods I'm never taking it
out of my ear right it's incredible
there training us it allows son
oh yeah it's incredible yeah what it
yeah before we down so that your we die
are they gonna have implants you're
already hooked into the a arm you're on
an AR platform that's augmented reality
so listening podcasts that's overlaying
your world with because AR AR has
multiple components which can be visual
and audio can really actually and also
like once they start tuning into like
Google yep and like saying where you are
that's a true AR application in Siri
like if it starts to say like hey you're
supposed to take a left turn to get into
this building go up you know seven or
four elevators Adam had some issues
getting in so we're gonna give a hard
time the others I go get him in the
lobby and everyone looks at me weird but
so let me tell you this though I went in
LA and I wish that I remembered the
organization because I'd love to give
him credit for this but it's a VR
application and this young kid was an
advertising agency that I think his
father ran and he said to me hey come
look at this I want to show you this new
demo and so I went this probably two to
that years ago or maybe even three years
ago now and so he says put these goggles
on put them on and also I'm standing on
top of the Freedom Tower
yeah right and in it all of a soon as I
put the goggles on I started looking
around and I have headphones on and I
could hear wind duh and then he goes
move your right foot 6 inches to like
this step off the ledge no even better
and when I move my foot there's a rope
that they have laid on the ground while
I put the goggles on so now it was
sudden there's a my foot feels a rope
I see a rope as I found walking in
between the two towers and I hear wind
and when I go to move my feet they turn
on a light fan and now my the rest of my
body feels wind blowing so the thing
about the sensory although like visual
audio rope touching your foot and you
feel the wind I wouldn't walk like nah
so turns out it's like 9 out of 10
people don't walk yeah I'm good
it's it's incredible actually there's a
new experience that's in so there we
backed one called spaces that
determinate or experienced okay there's
another one called sandbox and what they
are are group experiences where you're
all tethered up and you can see each
other in virtual reality and then you've
killed terminators your zombies or
whatever the escape the room of that
experience is it's really fascinating
because it gives you a good experience
of like anxiety and like things coming
at you
there is what what is crazy is so III
think they're so 7 million high in
headsets were sold ok ok so what market
size isn't that big right but I would
argue that only half of them are
actually set up so smaller so they sold
seven million in three and a half got
set up yeah I think so I think 50% of
our setup so 3.5 million our setup I
would argue that only 20% of them though
or active so that's like a market size
of like 700,000 but there's a company
that made 15 million dollars last year
in virtual reality a third-party built
an application that is on all the
devices that made 15 million dollars on
maybe seven hundred thousand on seven
hundred thousand users like it once we
scale the actual numbers like it is
captivating like this stuff is great and
the someone was asking me earlier today
when's the technology gonna be good
enough like it's good enough it's just
harder to use and the new device that's
coming out next month I'm like an
advertisement for for facebook facebook
is Facebook is releasing something
called the oculus quest and it's an
all-in-one headset you don't need a
computer you literally just unbox it put
it on your head and you can you can do
all the applications that basically
everything that's been built for the
high-end computer stuff so it's
fascinating the airpot example because
audio is obviously exploding and do you
think that that is because audio was
exploding and then the device of an air
pod empowered more people to listen or
do you think the air pod creation
empowers the explosion of audio like is
it the the medium or is it the device
that leads
so I think it's about persistence okay
so I think okay the difference between a
laptop and a mobile phone are not that
much different in computer power it's
basically like you have a computer in
your pocket or a computer on device but
the main difference is contacts so I
work on my desktop when I need to sit
down and it's bold world some people
probably only run on their mobile phone
but but the reason that the mobile phone
took off so fast was that there were
these intermitted spots where you could
do work or play games so the bathroom
the Train I'm willing to bet that what
do you think ten maybe twenty percent of
phone usage is in the bathroom oh I bet
for early adoption I bet it was for of
the smartphone I bet it was like 50
percent whoa early adoption
yeah yeah now I would be less it bids
like we're using it all the time yeah
yeah yeah but yes I bet it was a huge
part of it yeah I always I always
thought just like focusing on toilet
games I and and so by it what I mean by
it's about persistence though is like
the mobile phone became more persistent
than the desktop just on usability yeah
and now we're moving to something that
is currently could always be in your
ears that is still accessing computer
and so you can suddenly start to see a
world where we're talking to our phone
constantly and it's almost a me it you
could tether audio applications from
your phone to your you know what I want
so badly like just give me the answers
and tell me who the person is like I
want to leave the airport in and when
the air pod knows who you're meeting
with well just not even who I'm meeting
with but just like you run into somebody
where there's a conference on the street
in a coffee shop - Red Rock right we're
deaf tell me who the hell this person is
I mean the glasses are definitely gonna
do that yeah you you would have to have
a way of identifying which Bluetooth I
mean like if people are enabled like
there's a way there's a everywhere every
system if every system was connected you
could do it for sure but just like
that's a use case right direction
really definitely a use case in the part
that I always go to is I every was a
calm I would never get an implant
brain I'm like [ __ ] you're telling
me that if all of a sudden you can think
but a question and get the thought and
get the answer immediately you wouldn't
be interested in that I think yes well
you just got Google in your brain yeah
I'm talking also people have surgery
that are just purely cosmetic people
will probably have surgery for well she
was actually really international yeah
she was actually really irrational and
it would be a very human thing to be all
like yeah sure we'll like fix our noses
and whatever but not fix our brains
yeah let's not look it let's not put
anything in my brain though that's too
dangerous yeah have you looked at neural
link or like was it colonel - colonel
neural link there's another one called
pin drill mix and I don't know so I
looked into that in a wasp that looks
like maybe two years old yeah so I
looked into the space I I mean it's
early well yeah and mostly we just named
all the whole bodies and there's two of
the best founders in our lifetime are
working on them but it's still and
that's very very true and the and it's
gonna cost a lot of money and it also
you have to go through medical
compliance stuff that Brian Brian
Johnson for those that don't know Brian
Johnson saw what brain tree right I
think any sort of colonel and it's
basically an implantable device I
actually think they call it an mental
prosthetic like he's very careful yeah
the way that he described it was just
smart I like my prosthetic but yeah but
he committed I think 100 million dollars
of his own personal capital to fund this
thing so like expensive my paid
understatement it that literally he
couldn't raise the money had to
personally put the money up Oh
completely and I I think it's gonna be
passionate people who are gonna rational
people doing irrational things who are
gonna change that industry and the Elon
again like he's putting I think he's
putting almost the capital I don't think
he raised money for a neuro-link it's
probably like the early days of the
what's the whole one the hole in the
ground for incompetent government yeah
yeah I have a wild theory I don't think
that he's boring holes in the ground for
traffic
I think he's practicing for Mars oh it's
brilliant we need to learn about this
well the the so I think this is true and
of course
Twitter will correct as if I'm wrong on
this at some point but I'm pretty sure
you're always right and cannot be right
there twitter has reminded me many times
I'm usually not right oh but I think
that on Mars it's gonna be really
difficult for us to live above ground
based on some of the atmospheric
conditions yeah so there's a theory that
the best way if we get to Mars is
actually have you read red rising now
and what's that Oh fantastic series okay
and it's about basically what you're
talking about we're gonna be living
beneath the surface of Mars and maybe
this is where this theory came from
there's no I don't I don't think well
maybe it could have been it was just
it's a sci-fi book basically everything
in sci-fi books come from from very
jeweled builds those who says it they're
like you know if you want to see the
future like we you know look at sigh
fires yeah I mean Isaac Asimov basically
predicted artificial intelligence and he
did and I Robot and in psycho in the
foundation and then the I mean I'm
trying to build magic with VR and that's
basically Harry Potter did you see a
ready player one oh yeah amazing
fantastic like probably one of the
better movies I've seen in a while and
the way that it was done was just crazy
enough that it was like whoa this is
possible and just rational enough where
you could see like we're gonna get there
it after that movie came out I was so
happy because it's gonna translate what
virtual reality is to a millions of
people who have never thought what a
what it would be like yeah and that's
exactly what it is and it worked really
really well they did the headset stuff
really well they showed how the world is
gonna change bad and good really I don't
want to out this person but there's a an
older gentleman that I'm just fascinated
with and one day some of our personal
reactive is waiting people turn off
personal reality don't you got that
virtual reality on your computer and
what he said what he meant was like
you're going into a virtual reality in
your leg it's it's not to your face but
you are going to search from reality I
was like you're actually really right so
the difference between a the the desktop
and VR is immersion so we
currently interact with all this data
with through a window so we're looking
at a window yep to that data where now
we can actually fully immerse ourselves
in that data and feel and experience it
I think that we the killer there are
three things that VR is epic for like I
amazing for the surprising one to me is
Fitness so yeah what talk tonal and a
bunch of these are all getting close we
have actually our box VR the Y you are
like they're a couple it was just
surprising like when you go to X wanted
you so this when you go to view I did I
started box BR and fit X if fit XR runs
box VR and then Y you are is that is the
other one and I don't want founders to
get mad at you that you're not
mentioning your oh if your portfolios oh
dude well I hope they're not mad either
that's fine you only invested in 300
companies yeah we could just sit here in
listing things off alright go back to
view but Fitness but but when you go on
VR Twitter its it's all about how many
pounds are being lost using the device
and in its hitting a different
demographic of a person who might not
want to go to Equinox
like they want to play games but they
don't want to you know go somewhere else
have you seen move to a different
location the black mirror episode where
they're on and they're peddling and they
got a state pedal no I have a man it's
basically they're peddling a real
bicycle that's stationary
and they're all in a room and they're
you know essentially enslaved there to
some degree and they're looking on a
screen and they have to keep peddling
but I keep the lights on type stuff yeah
I mean we're pretty close to that
oh listen I'll give I'll give my
girlfriend a hard time like she's got an
Apple watch and she will literally like
it says stand up she'll stand up like
like hey you gotta get Stokes in don't
like you gotta like compete with your
tell you what to do you have to like
compute your friend like that's personal
reality into something that is I know
it's it this machine is telling you what
to do
there's a digital world that is that we
live in already and we're just getting
closer and closer to being able to see
it with our eyes like it's already there
all around us all the time like all this
data all the stuff
well Elon will tell you that were in a
simulation anyways doesn't matter
yeah now we're building a simulation in
a simulation so like yeah it's the movie
Inception that's what we're gonna be in
all right so arv our big deal okay yeah
believer do you think AR or VR hits mass
like mainstream adoption first I think
VR hits first and nice contrarian to the
market yeah why well okay visual they
are will not hit until after virtual
reality if visual so I'm okay alright
you guys I think everybody here and I
think they're here and I just say iPod
like a imagine if we saw at iPods I mean
crazy I mean we do it's just digital now
it's all applications yeah but now now
now we just put it more full of that a
phone app in there multiple of those
though and that like I have lots of
iPods the I think VR hits first because
AR is a very very difficult technology
challenge it has to recognize the
external world and then overlay data on
top of that world where VR literally
just needs to replace your world with a
digital screen and it's they're both
difficult but like I think ARS
technology is just it's a couple it's
three years behind like it's literally
the timeline is three years I'm behind
I like this I'm gonna disagree with you
okay perfect go yeah no I'm not gonna
buy the way a lot of people disagree
with me there are lots of people did
sorry I really you're not alone yeah I
agree with what you just said but I
think the piece that I would take past
that would be even though the technology
is quite a lot worse or not as developed
as via or the method in which it is
utilized is more important than the
quality of the technology and people are
it's less scary to engage with AR than
it is VR like I fundamentally think that
a lot of mass consumers are like no way
I'm putting those goggles on sitting on
my couch and like look at my clues well
it means that we have to deliver a good
enough service true yeah they are they
are and that's why I went with fitness
so Fitness being the first of the thing
I haven't even said the other two the
other is the others training so training
which basically means edge
so we're getting closer and closer to
the matrix you know like I know kungfu
yeah that we're there basically think
kung fu is the first training networks
no its enterprise so training for we
have a company called apex officer that
trains law enforcement vantage point for
HR like different types of training in
different its context is what diff is
different about the training and then oh
man I forget I forget the name of the
company and and the founder is gonna
kill me for this but in 2015 I met him
and he said I'm gonna use basically
synthetic environments right or
artificial environments to do interviews
and so it was like if you were a
customer support person they would
literally the interview would be we're
just gonna put you in this environment
and like BAM somebody just called pand I
just got an email now your bosses just
sent unique like and you can be like so
so what a job for a day Walmart is
already training their employees hired
is the name you go Walmart's already
training their employees with virtual
reality for Black Friday's really yeah
so what do they like their training kung
fu for Black Friday they come out and
they go I know kung fu' they do because
it's a high-stress situation yep and we
will we as humans if we experience
something multiple times we come more
desensitized to it so you can be ready
for it and you can do what you feel you
should be doing rather than like the
sometimes the response is
fight-or-flight and like you know that's
I guess what they experienced on the rig
on the Black Friday's in uh in the army
we did these like VR simulations and you
put the goggles on or whatever and you
get in like they're almost like skeleton
vehicles so they kind of feel like a
vehicle you're shedding like in the
Gunther whatever and they put you
through the simulations and like and I
was kind of janky like cartoonish you
know content but like hey man that dude
over there on the right side of the
screen shooting at you like why shoot
back right early uh completely in like
something over the radio just said ex
like what are you gonna do so I I did
something really cool in VR recently
which was I've been using it so I've
actually found deals in VR so I actually
put on goggles and then yeah I like set
up meeting times with with startups and
I've invested in three companies that I
met originally in virtual reality in a
meeting and I'd say three meetings you
realize that that sounds insane exactly
hell we live in the future or in the
future we're just pulling you back to
reality for yeah just for this podcast I
came back and I'm from the future I'm
trying to articulate what it looks like
the and the that is a big part of my job
by the way I have to like retell the
stories of like how this technology
impacts people but for me personally I
am running a I took eight of our VR
portfolio companies I actually haven't
even talked about this anywhere so this
is the view you see what we do off the
chain we get exclusive yeah you get to
hear about the the firm makes me sound
like a reporter and I couldn't do that
we're not reporting but we I have taken
eight of our companies who are in our
portfolio already went through an
accelerator or we invested in and every
two weeks we meet up in VR and we guys
do well I hold them accountable on
numbers and metrics and then we do what
an accelerator does like it's a VR
accelerator and we hold them accountable
on the on metrics and then what ends up
happening is we talk around one topic
for instance like someone brought up
I'm nervous about launching like
launching my application so someone else
said I've already launched this is how
Facebook works for launching and this is
how to become a launch partner that's
information I couldn't have given them
but the group can collaborate and solve
the questions like basically what you're
talking about is rather than use like
Google Hangouts and have seven people
you're doing it in VR yes yes but the no
better than exponentially better than
anything us so one-to-one I would say
they're equivalent like if I'm only
working if doing this this is okay
Google Hangouts or in VR like it works
both ways but in collaborative
environments where you need to work on a
whiteboard you have to solve a difficult
problem getting into a room together
this is it's the difference between this
and Google Hangouts got it like it it's
difficult to quantify but I would argue
that it's about 5 to 10 X better for
collaborative environments so for my
situation where I have a group of people
who are all talking it's fantastic like
the group but I also ran an investor day
in VR so all the investors had to get in
VR they had to jump into VR and meet
these companies man that really kind of
probably felt on a bunch of the idiots
well we could figure it out well no so
what I in order to mitigate that risk I
them all into our office oh you did like
real reality so we had like this merger
of reality VR where the investors were
on one side and the companies were on
the other side of the virtual reality
did did you see the photo suck walking
into f8 and everyone's got on the thing
like it was it kind of like that uh it
was well so I I didn't have that many
people but and they would how I set it
up was more like investors hang out and
have appetizers and then they can
opportunistically jump into headset and
they meet two at a time in each headset
it worked really really well I'm very
happy about it it was a small-scale
representation of what I hope to scale
out to a bigger audience it's gonna be
fun it's really fun so that's VR VR AR
yeah what about the oceans ok oceans I
I'm obsessed with the oceans why okay do
you want the long story yeah or the
short story we can do whatever we want
long story okay
the long story starts at a bachelor
party okay perfect okay
what's yours knows my brothers okay and
will he kill you for telling me stories
no okay well tell the tell the more
extremes to read it's no Billy Billy
sorry um the no so I was at a bachelor
party and we were at a bar and we were
playing hot takes you said that like
you're not supposed to be at the bar the
but we're playing hot X uh-huh take is
like something you believe that the rest
of the world would hate you for okay is
a clip so like for example just to give
other people an example like an example
would be like ja Rule as the Grizz
rapper of all time
like right now that would be the hottest
take of all time you think so yeah be a
very hot take because that fire festival
verno like stuff no but I would argue
that's why fire festival was fire for us
because ja rule because not rule so it
makes him so I would have taken to the
opposite side of that so okay so that
that's what I'm saying is that basically
a ja ja rule like nothing like just
barking at people on the CD to get you
famous yet
and so I so my hot take was that climate
change is not a thing jeez okay alright
and so so but this is why I'm giving you
the the like full story so we is this
something that you have to believe if
you say it so you believe it you know it
but but also everyone's just like making
fun of each other yeah it's not a like
coordinated game I just want to make
sure that when the president read this
like when they look at this they say
Adam Draper doesn't book but I said but
I said that and then what I said was
then my friend almost punch me in the
face okay because he was so viscerally
he had this visceral reaction he didn't
know anything about climate change but
like everyone got super angry about my
reaction to it and I didn't know
anything about climate change so it's so
like I'm not gonna like but it was it
was like strictly off of the media
telling me it's a thing I said it's not
a thing um we're crypto people people
like hey I'm gonna check check the facts
so that next year the next 12 months I
read books I learned about climate
change I learned about global warming
and and they what do you think now okay
so I think it's a ridiculous debate
because it's not even about whether or
not the climate the earth is warming
which by the way the way that we use to
measure the data I don't completely
trust but I do believe that climate
change is happening okay okay
but it's the argument isn't it or not
it's happening but isn't global warming
and climate change they could be the
same thing or they could be they are the
same thing a used a different word to
describe again is basically climate
change global warming was the first word
everyone used for climate change yeah
but if they let's just say that the
climate was changing the other windows
getting colder which I'm not claiming
that it's still but that B climate
change that is still about me well they
if they rebranded global warming because
people were arguing
that was their argument against it I'm
just like three years late got it yeah
you're three years eight but like no one
actually checked the no one read books
no one checks everything everyone just
had an opinion and I like to figure out
like where these friction points are
figure out where the truth is right like
that's where discoverers of truth and so
what I did I'm not gonna say that I know
for a fact what the truth is but I know
that I believe that the climate is
warming or getting more extreme let's
say getting more string which is what
climate change is they're kind of
extreme it is but the argument is about
really its are humans causing it or is
it unnatural yep system so my thought is
like because I believe that climate
change is happening whether or not it's
human caused or not like we should
probably the ocean is the regulator of
the earth's temperature many people
don't know that
yeah it's the the reason that we exist
is because there's enough like
dissolving of h2o that we don't get hit
by the whole heat wave and and co2
actually doesn't have anything to do
with client like it very little to do
with climate it's all it's mostly h2o
and so the ocean has a you know
trash-heap the size of Texas in the
middle of it so we might as well clean
it up to like check it off the box of
like human caused climate change okay
and so but okay this is the long way of
saying you know I care okay you Kara
think I found the person with babies
Adam driver and I'm part of oceans
Anonymous yeah it's a it's a room of one
I go into VR and I go to my oceans and
now Anonymous meetings every week all
right
but basically oceans have a huge problem
and the problem is lost some people the
people dropped off with another people
are saying very interesting so there's a
couple other ocean okay well well I care
too good the oceans have it's a business
model problem basically everyone thinks
of it as a non-profit okay
because and naturally the United States
and every country's issue is that no one
the ocean yeah so our incentive is
actually throw trash in the middle of
the water you know everyone's incentive
is to throw it in the middle of water so
that it's not a problem
so naturally it's a tragedy of the
Commons problem so like naturally it
became a trash heap so the key is to
change the business model of the ocean
from a tragedy of the Commons thing to a
ownership model of an ocean so what I'm
trying to say on this podcast is I own
the ocean okay it's mine and and what
are you gonna do with it
well it's my problem now do you want
some I don't know what are the problems
but well can I make money but there's
huge markets in it so aquaculture is a
250 billion dollar a year what is that
word fish farming fish farming okay got
a forum $250 go people they need fish
for me yeah and there's no technology
infrastructure it's literally just and
we're and we're literally like just like
you would create animals to then eat
them yeah we're just creating fish to
you don't need them okay Lee and with
there are seaweed farms and other farms
just like let's just see okay hold on
pause seaweed farms really weird that I
know this I went super deep and I want
to start a seaweed farm at one point I
sort of still do okay we can partner up
let's do let's find some young kid who
wants to go play in the ocean and do the
seaweed farming yeah hey there's
somebody who's is anyone gonna if you
don't want to uh if you want to start a
seaweed farm reach out to Adam but
continue seaweed farm so there's a kid
the reason why I figured this out was
there's a kid I think in Seattle maybe
or someone the Pacific Northwest what he
did was he was young like 16 18 years
old sorta seaweed farm and what he was
doing was his whole play in the local
paper said something like he realized
that there was a special type of seaweed
that if you grew it you could then put
it into cow feed and that cow feed could
drastically reduce the gas output of the
cows a kcal farts so making vegan cows
go there already well well kind of but
in the sense of this was just an
additive to the food they were already
eating and I drastically reduced the co2
emission of the cows of the cow for and
there at one point I don't know if this
is still people believe this or not but
the cow farts were a major good
to global this whole thing was one of
the best ways to attack global warming
is to get council stop farting so much
and the best way to do that it should
put a seaweed from the ocean to the
caffeine sounds crazy oh yeah I looked
at it
wild business because here's why your
point about nobody owns the ocean it's
like if you want to start a farm you
gotta buy farmland
yeah you're buying it from somebody and
you don't have the ocean you don't have
to buy the ocean now sometimes with what
you can do is you can actually get
something to pay you to do it because
there's all sorts of things around this
a cute aquaculture all this stuff and
and so I talked to a couple of people
and there's a bunch of very wealthy
people around the world especially in
Asia correct oh I own an island like
I'll just go hire you know 200 people
from like home country and I almost get
them to farm seaweed completely the
problem is that the seaweed has to stay
fresh till you get it somewhere and so
the whole seaweed farm culture is like
very underrated I think it's all what
could be big company like right now this
was like the seaweed that is crispy
around sushi rolls and stuff I think is
like a huge I think it's like one
company makes all the seaweed sushi
wraps basically well like huge
businesses are in the water
logistics shipping could carrier
freights all those things water there
are a lot of problems with the water and
that's why I'm investing in startups
that can solve those process so you're
talking about surface water like what's
going on surface below what's underneath
the ocean we don't know anything down
there yeah no there's uh we have a
hundred percent high-resolution capture
of Mars yeah and we have only I think
it's 5% of the Earth's seabed at high
resolution in for pictures so we
actually buy a resolution of Mars photos
then of the Earth's water surface so we
can take better pictures of space then
we can of our of our own planet yeah
yeah and so why is that well basically
that's a great question my all ideas
great question so my answer to that is
just rolling out the grid question my
answer to that is I believe
in the 50s JFK and Russia said we're
going to space and over the next 10
years
I like how just JFK not the u.s. it was
gonna be us JFK well he said he has the
speech that's like we're gonna go to
space cuz we you know we want to it's a
great speech you should listen to it
just for inspiration sometimes but the
in over 10 years we got to space and
then we got to the moon Russia by the
way they announced their intention to go
to space through Twitter bot sorry radio
waye yeah I couldn't resist and the and
so what happened was NASA got an insane
amount of funding around the same time
though in this in the early 60s they
started another program called Noah okay
it has been a thousand x less funded
than nasa what and what is Noah so Noah
is the monitoring and observation and
research of the Seas basically and so
what the figure would actually stands
for National Oceanic Association in
another a or an age no 10 wasn't it Noa
Association Association does an
organization and the and so the I so
basically my answer is underfunded
that's why so the reason we captured
space captured competition and the
imagination I grew that and so we went
and we won we won the moon and do you
think we went to the moon I do yeah I
think we went to the moon why well they
have that experiment where they bounce a
awesome there's a mirror up on the moon
or a reflection getting and the Advanta
lasers off of it to prove that there's
something that is not from I mean it
means that we could have crash-landed
there but like we'd something Oh is
there so there is a mirror that they
there's like yeah there's some but
there's a big bang theory about it I
asked the guy one time I like to joke
around in bed God we don't really go
like you know we can't stream Sunday
nights like how did we go to the moon
yeah boy how are we swimming in the 60s
and why from them there are like these
polar
situations like that where it's like
there's no way because like I can't even
screw in a lightbulb
like I'm obviously joking around
but I did say to one guy said hey do you
believe in I won't say who it is but
he's hit me with dude there's no way we
went to the moon nobody can show us the
flag up there yeah cause like my old
furniture they're like oh it's on the
dark side like it's over there I was
like man we got all we got up hill
battle to get people right there but I
do think that we have like a land rover
on Mars or what people don't know about
the moon landing was it wasn't just once
it was like what six times in four years
or something right but but it doesn't it
the reason why I bring it up is oh we
haven't gone back like we haven't really
gone back much yeah six times
yeah and it's been 80 years seven years
whatever well here's the crazy part so
like imagine all the conspiracy theories
around just the moon from 60 70 years
ago - if we land on Mars oh my god
people are gonna be going crazy about
every conspiracy theory in the book oh
yeah completely
that's just VR yeah like that like it's
not real yeah we're gonna we're in a
simulation simulation all right what
what is the biggest opportunity in the
ocean like if you could say if you said
if one company solves ax so the biggest
enabler of opportunity which I would
argue is the biggest thing is persistent
internet on the water so on the water
under the water both but to to enable
under and over to be able to communicate
right now there's a problem where
submarines can't really talk to
airplanes like it's a weird problem
there aren't very many people who run
into this problem yeah I will say but
also just the submarines they yeah
that's an airplane but but I think of it
like if there's a network on the ocean
then suddenly it's gonna enable more
like enable more fishermen to be out
there an able more data to be harness I
just like you know without GPS uber
wouldn't have been enabled yep like
without like they're these little
technology hurdles and right now we we
have
Internet covered on land pretty well not
everywhere but pretty well there's
nothing on the ocean and so in order to
get data like photo video whatever data
from a buoy off shore to land it's very
expensive so cheapening that will allow
for new companies new stuff so I would
say communications on the like there's
probably some kind of some kind of
metric of I'm just getting a water yeah
it's fine we got that into the ocean
there's probably something around like
the number of connected devices per
square mile on my end versus the number
of connected devices per square mile in
the ocean it's probably like egregiously
oh yeah swayed in one direction oh yeah
and I would also say like success based
on what I think that there are a lot of
things that could be really really big
businesses like I think the answers to
most of humanity's future 50-year
problems like how do we feed 9 billion
people how do we give fresh water to 9
billion people how do we our answer by
the ocean and like I think people are
blind to it because we're very crypto
people will appreciate it we're very
Terra maximalist like because we're here
we like have farmed animals 2014 was the
first year that we farmed more fish than
we caught which I would argue on land is
like 99.9 percent of all food is caught
I mean is farmed yeah and so we still
have like 40 like we just said we didn't
we've had to flip inning yeah we had a
flip inning of the ocean of the oceans
that's it here I'm gonna write that down
there's my next blog post the flipping
of the oceans Jesus Christ okay alright
so the other thing about the ocean
that's super interesting is like we've
even gotten the crypto okay good
no but think about the ocean that is is
kind of fascinating me is just not only
do we not know anything but then it
seems like every time somebody goes and
does something crazy in the ocean we
figure stuff out we're like whoa what
the hell is that
yuck did you who's the billionaire guy
who I think he's been there amazing
multi-millionaire who he keeps going to
the depths of the ocean like the deepest
points James II James Cameron is one
okay so he's gonna be guy right yeah
he's the movie guy
there's another guy who runs a company
in Seattle who's built a he's trying to
make it to tourists there's a guy I
think he's not from the US and he keeps
going down in these one-man submarines
yeah and he's just like yeah I also I
went to the deepest part of the Indian
Ocean appear like what and he's like
yeah you guys trying to go to space I
was in the ocean yeah no my lord
like I've absorbed Indian Ocean I think
there is a segment of people who are
sort of like why are we going to space
like I think I'm doing both like I've
backed space companies too but like I I
also do have a hey why go against
gravity we could use gravity as the
energy source to Gay's things down there
and by creating an ownership model in
the ocean like showing that you can make
money in the ocean I actually think the
trash heap naturally will clean itself
up so my so short I am the solution to
climate change dude now what I thought
you're gonna say you want to know one of
the things that fascinates me that
people don't know what is the underwater
cables yes
like people have no clue they just think
like it's magic like yeah I just used
this internet thing and it just like
flew around the world real quick there's
a great book called the Victorian
Internet the Victorian Internet yeah and
basically it's about the first people
laying cables to create the telegraph
lines between Europe and the US and how
they failed four times and this this guy
was the it's not more the more sky if
who created Morse code it's not him but
there was a predecessor who laid the
cables to make this happen and how it
was his just like quest to make sure
that we connected Europe and the US I
mean there's these big big cables like
they're huge like dude you've been an
ocean that's pretty big place yeah like
they're huge and in its own well they're
also like fit they're like huge freaking
yeah and just think about like when one
of those cables goes out it's like how
much progress is lost oh yeah
devastating yeah and how really if you
figure out where it is like that's a
huge insurance
problem like that's trillions of dollars
that are just like down like in every
country not only the u.s. is like it's
national security stuff too like oh yeah
you could imagine that if all of a
sudden we or somebody else knew where
ours were or we knew where there's were
and all of a sudden they decided eh I'm
just gonna go cut this well also the
Victorian poet up the Victorian internet
also talks about how the Telegraph led
to the first level of hackers where
people were like creating coded messages
and decoding them because of and I mean
it's just fascinating it's fascinating
stuff what what uh what's the one thing
that you're excited about in space in
space yeah I'm really excited about
software why in space why because it's
not there the okay so basically well I'm
gonna reference one of our companies but
there's a company logo to show whatever
you yeah oh I'm chillin but there's a
human real qos and what they do is
basically they saw that we he was
working at a company called spire that
was a satellite mini micro sim mini
sadly microsatellites me he's a small
the small satellite manufacturer and
it's big company and he realized the
company's small set all these all these
hardware engineers were building the
software for this device and he was like
this is this doesn't make sense so he
created an open-source community that
was for space software right which is
wild there is an open-source space
software community and then he realized
that it's difficult to test software in
space so every satellite has basically
the same sensors so they have it's like
what's the red sensor and the lasers and
heat and like they have basically seven
sensors and then what but they all
coordinate differently just like a
computer computer is basically all the
same pieces but there's an operating
system that ties them all together they
were trying they're trying to be the
Android of this space but they also can
be sort of AWS and so they are actually
alive on two satellites right now where
people can test their software that's
pretty cool in space dude there was
24 months ago there was a bunch of these
space companies that all started to
build stuff like they were doing
scientific testing on the ISS they were
doing all this stuff and that was big
when it was what mining asteroids yeah
got really like everyone was talking
about that and then also you looked into
a space manufacturing Oh super cool like
people gonna send up stuff they're gonna
manufacture in space they set it back
down what you would and what you can do
is you can build enormous things better
that you because it's just flown out
there so like 3d printing and spaces can
be like the killer app of 3d printing is
really space manufacturing it is not on
land well it's it's iterative processing
I guess or houses I'm really excited
about 3d printing houses same yeah
because it you could give the house like
you know the TOMS shoes yep you could
give a house by buying a house but but
the other piece of it that's interesting
is knowing how fast it can be built how
efficiently right in terms of costs they
can be built but also I think that it
changes the wave if you know that you're
going to move into a 3d house you
immediately are okay with lower
expectations in terms of the square
footage you need oh yeah right like like
it completely changes the way that
people think about their home and we go
from oh I need a basketball court in my
house and that would be really sweet too
you know what like I'm pretty okay
living in this 3d printed house because
this it's cool I can talk about it but
whatever it's a a New Age type of
quote-unquote wealth but without the
price tag completely no I think three I
mean I think they're gonna be reasonably
priced and I think you really don't need
that much space that's what like yeah I
mean at boost we do provide housing and
the accommodations are not huge they are
it's like a dome or a bigger or smaller
guys like a dorm room and it has bunk
beds and so these teams are literally
stacked on top of each other
dude do you have a lottery for who gets
top of its bottom that's a brilliant
idea we should actually do it just do it
in VR though Maddy Maddy as you are but
I just gave you an idea I wanna see that
Maddy we should do that
all right so Krypto this thing that
you're supposed to come here to talk
about yeah
I'm here so first of all well it did I
already talked about Brian Armstrong so
yeah yeah we just sucker people in with
the Brian Armstrong story then let them
listen to space and oceans yeah yeah oh
well he invited because I have a couple
of questions one your father didn't rape
her yeah always tells a story about how
he initially got excited about digital
currencies with a song and asking to buy
a sword
was that you so no he's actually telling
a tangential story a he was in curve I
was in Korea and there's this game that
25% of the country was he playing called
like legends okay and they and he was
being told by someone that they're so
got his gift for Christmas was a like
thousand dollars sword or like fifteen
hundred dollars sort or some expensive
assorted this was pre crypto pre digital
currencies pre and because I'm if I'm
clear it's like early 2000s um
yeah early 2000s and if my dad started
realizing that not only software was
gonna be expensive in the digital world
it's also gonna be like items like you
can develop value of things in a digital
world depending on how much time you're
spending in those places and so he I
think that was his deep-seated like
thought yeah but kept through when
cryptocurrency started to pop up he and
he did so we always debate about which
of us invested in a crypto company first
and so this was gonna get to because I
if I remember correctly he passed on
quite base or he didn't invest in you
did so yes okay he he invested in a
company called coin lab before me coin
lab okay all right which is no longer
around and that was an L for him yeah it
was oh and I did coin based and then I
brought it to him and I said you should
you should do this deal and he they were
they he and someone else were like no we
already have one like we got one that
they're not gonna be it's a
winner-take-all whatever and I make it
my dad was actually very enthusiastic
I'm making it sound like he was the one
saying that my dad's never the ones
the he's like a crazy positive person
the but he did think like okay we have
one like you know if it's not a
winner-take-all someone they'll do well
but he also at the same time it was a
mining company and we both put in a
purchase order for future mining mind
Bitcoin of a significant amount of
Bitcoin at the time because the price
efficient was like you know five to
thirty dollars like that was basically
the range and they never delivered on
that that account which led my dad to
actually buy the US Marshal Cole got it
because it was that many Bitcoin that he
was supposed to happen so he bought it
at a much more expensive price later the
the Marshall story is crazy but yeah but
the fact that you invested in coin base
first and he didn't yeah you know
Marshall going not and not a bad
investment he he called me that morning
and he said he called me I was on my way
to work I was just gonna turn on the El
Camino you guys need to know these
details these are important details of
course about where I was what mine said
I was in a they don't have virtual
reality this is the next best thing I
was listening to Taylor Swift in my Jeep
and what song the will shake it off just
to get in the in the right mindset and
then followed by Tim McGraw and then my
dad called me and literally he didn't
even say like hey it's dad he said he
said should I do it and I didn't know
what that meant I was like I have no
context I'm just driving to work and he
said should I do it I said I do why and
he said should I put it in my bid for
the marshal coin at the u.s. marshal
coin he made the assumption that
everyone's gonna bid under the market
price and so he bid over and I know and
I was like you know if I could I would
because I'm like such a true believer
and like we're in a weird spot in the
market it feels like a good time and so
he hung up on me I didn't know what he
was gonna buy the whole thing I thought
it was gonna be like I'm putting in a
bid for some you know like you put in a
bid and bought like a certain amount and
like he bought he bought like he bought
the whole cart
the next like five day and I didn't find
that that out until like the next two
days later when it was released
everywhere in media like it yeah it's
all over and I was like you put the
whole thing you've done you got the
whole thing would it be nice to get the
heads up but also pray that were right
if you're right you're a legend if not
oh man yeah well and then I give him the
advice I was like the final say like if
I said no like he probably was second
guess he might have still gotten it but
he may be a second guessed his thought
yeah so that's the marring so what your
thoughts on crypto today crypto is
awesome
why today I think I don't think I've
been this excited about crypto are you
ever wait let's let's get your
affinities on the table first okay
bitcoin believer or non-believer
believer big believer yeah like global
reserve currency a hundred years from
now believer or like I'm not again I
like okay first I believe that if the
impossible can happen
so like could Bitcoin be disrupted yes I
agree that today I believe it Bitcoin
will be a global reserve currency okay
I agree with that timeline and obviously
the deadline isn't don't hold them to it
please do hold me to it now what do you
think it is 50 years so what what I do
say there are two predictions as so one
is I say in the next 15 years 10 years
actually I say 10 years there will be
more digital currency than feel okay
okay well the value of digital
currencies in there anymore ex ago I and
I'm it what kidding I'm kidding okay
then you're gonna be delirious stayed
okay
but the so I believe I believe that to
be true in the next 10 years global
reserve currency I think things happen
fast when they happen but I still think
it's 25 years like I think it's reason
Trust is being built right now it's
gonna work for certain like cultures
certain nation certain places
I still like I think Bitcoin works the
way the internet works where it's like I
don't talk about the internet like I
just talked about using products on me
yeah and so like I think Bitcoin works
when I can just buy things using maybe
it's US dollars maybe the denomination
is like like the US Dollars digital
currency yeah right what eight seven
percent is in physical coins or notes
like the rest of its digital everybody
they type in more numbers on a like
alright what about I would love to know
how that actually works um a theorem I
believe that they're gonna be different
protocols for different things like I
think you know if you might I do think
lightnings gonna work I think we will be
able to use I think scale is not gonna
move we gotta go slow because I'm not
smart so bitcoin believer lightning what
anything is gonna work so why I think
play so weird like he's talked about
lightning so the same reason that I
thought Bitcoin was gonna work like
there are really really smart people
building really really great things it's
probably the best execution we're
singing crypto behind maybe by Nance I
yeah I mean I think it's just good like
I think lightnings you see like at the
how do people make money if lightning
works like what are the ways that you
think about if lightning works as a
layer to scaling technology the places
to invest will be blank what's blank
well then it becomes sort of like how to
be a gateway for either real world
things or natively digital things so I
would probably if I if that just all of
a sudden happens I would probably invest
in VR meets crypto like assets in that
world I believe non fungible tokens are
undervalued like crazy why the reason is
I believe that most opportunity lies in
regulatory uncertainty so crypto was a
good example oceans it's a good example
there are no laws on the ocean and I
think that non federal tokens are gonna
walk this line where they aren't an
asset it would be the equivalent of
regulating like beanie babies which is a
ridiculous
and I think that NF TS are going to be
able to get through all the regulatory
like fear and allow the end consumer to
use to use crypto without using crypto
and so like I I think that suddenly
we're all gonna be using these assets
these digital assets that represent like
a kitty or whatever when really it's
shown it's it's paving the education gap
to denominating this entire building in
a cryptocurrency like being able to set
auction off pieces of this building and
it's it's really about education at that
point do you think that the NFT is like
what's the timeline for to get through
the regulatory uncertainty are we
talking like I mean I think 12 my turn I
think it's more about like we just need
a good use case for the like we need a
good game I we need I have we even seem
good yet I think I'm good yet
like I think CNF teas to me are the
pervy example of great idea wrong time
I'm not farting I I just the chairs are
really squeaky it's a squeaky chair it's
a good audio room though this is a good
audio yeah it's fine we have experts in
the room but yeah no I think NF T's are
just undervalued because we don't really
know I I think you could build a good
game like you you need to people need to
stop thinking that they're starting at
the end like I just want someone who
really truly wants to build out a great
what's they get Magic the Gathering game
on the blockchain and then fiddle with
the blockchain as a tool that creates
new gamified experiences yes like I
think a lot of people think like they
launched and then everyone uses it and
like I I mean that's obviously not true
like I think the most views product is
crypto kitties in the crypto space
Bitcoin but crypto kitties in the actual
non-financial space what do you think
governments are gonna do how do they
play forget regular regulators like
security not security but like what does
central banks do etc okay so I'm gonna
give you two worlds alright the first
world is my fare to the banking system
world
I believe all I really truly want are
better services like at the end of the
day that's all I want I want all the
user cares about is can you help me do
what I want to do yeah I just like when
my when I want my money I want my money
when I want to pay for something I want
to pay for something I don't care if
it's the bank or Bitcoin it's just the
bank has developed such poor service
that they forgot who their customer was
and then on the other side Bitcoin is
developing more trust even though it
started as like a drug-dealing tool it's
developing more and more trust where
people just rely on it 24/7 uptime for
10 years is something that no one has
been able to so my whole theory here is
that people who trust machines and
algorithms more than they trust humans
and inherently banks are run by humans
the financial system fraud by humans but
Bitcoin is run by an algorithm compared
with that just can't fail in fact like
it can't can't is just like Derek could
be security concerns we 51% attacks all
that but like the way that it is
programmed is it never goes down and
back to the persistence like things
don't really get flipped on until
persistence happens like Bitcoin is a
persistent currency like there are no
bank hours like it's not I'm relying on
my bank to be open that's not a
persistent money like that isn't that's
a choppy money that I I can only access
my money for these hours that's a
ridiculous council the stock markets
closed more hours a week than it is open
all that kind of stuff right but the the
the best example of Bitcoin is so
Venezuela powers the power grid went
down the grid went down and everyone on
the Internet's been all up in arms about
this idea that like people are saying oh
Venezuela's power grid going down shows
the power of Bitcoin they're like how
the hell can you use Bitcoin without the
power right but what a number of
Venezuelans have posted different
stories on reddit and etc is look the
power grid was down the banking system
was down I have a generator
I turned my generator on I could not use
the legacy system I could not go on my
website for the bank I could not go to
the ATM I couldn't do it even though I
have power but the but the power grid is
down and because they could do that but
with Bitcoin all I have to do is I just
have I just have the network and as long
as I have power doesn't matter for
anybody
my country has power I can still access
my money because I can hit the Bitcoin
never sick
I think persistence is more value like I
think people don't because it by it
being there you can develop trust in it
and I think that's why you know uber is
this persistent it delivers certainty
like I know when the car is coming
around the corner I know that's
something like this next generation
doesn't know that we had to blindly wait
for cars or taxis like we had to like we
had to hope that someone was gonna show
up and then eventually you get a call
that's like oh we're like 30 minutes out
and you're like well I'll go back inside
like I I think that's like crazy there's
so much transparency so much certainty
yeah I think persistence I think that's
the power of Bitcoin persistent money
accessibility if there's energy that's
fair what do you think are the one or
two companies that somebody should build
in crypto that you haven't seen we're
good the things I'm excited about right
now that's sort of like good asking me
what I'm excited about
yeah you just took the question that's
your own question go ahead yeah I mean
what should they build okay build the
craziest possible thing but like what's
the craziest possible thing you could
imagine somebody building right now mmm
first you have to start with the word
global I'm gonna send you a pitch deck
with just the word global ready ready
this is it got an ocean city and oceans
built with the economy's denominated in
Bitcoin okay
that would be the craziest thing I get
the Ocean City I've actually seen people
pitch this before which is basically
something that floats in the ocean and
acts almost like an island but a
standalone standalone city and all of
the commerce that's done is Thomas it a
single global currency called Bitcoin
mm-hmm which connects them to the rest
of the world okay
so that would be one of the craziest
things but if we're talking about like
applications I think somebody's gonna
tweet at us and be like I'm building a
city in the ocean will you come visit I
hope so yeah crypto portfolios are
already underway
I was good somebody on the livestream
just say crypto portfolios are already
underwater we're already building the
digital land of the ocean um I would say
so what I'm really excited about right
now are user interfaces so like I think
that there's I was a drawing this to a
other thing well man you look like my
notebook you just draw a bunch of stuff
everyone looks like I use it you can't
really hey you can't read any of the
words and then we'll just look at people
like did you get it but I think that
it's like the power of decentralized
services is the difference first the
difference is basically like centralized
services let's take iTunes App Store the
app store the Apple App Store for it for
instance we interact with the user
interface that interface is governed by
a process at Apple and then that is
built on top of the internet that is a
open rails the difference between that
is completely controlled by Apple that
entire process now in the decentralized
world the governance system and the user
interface are separated so suddenly
augur could build their own interface
but I think what we're learning is that
they should just work on like different
dat's that's the DAP layer or the
governance layer the peer-to-peer
network should be building their
peer-to-peer network which is smart
contracts and so you're basically making
arbitration is that there shouldn't be
vertical integration but augur should
work on the protocol and then things
like veil should come along a building
or guess or but yes sir did you invest I
did okay and Gabe is it better they're
different they're different like you're
an animal you're a politician I'm but I
like but I generally do think they're
different well wait a - but that's like
I'm not an investor in Vail but I'm also
saying like they're just different
they're going they're gonna end up going
after different markets but it's two
separate interfaces using the same P the
same protocol that's built on top of the
know using the same DAP that's built on
the same protocol so like the stack
today is aetherium on the protocol the
DAP layer is augur and then the
interface is veil or or guesser
this is gonna gonna see this stack
replicated over a bunch of different do
you think so let's call that
fragmentation and right of the stack do
you think that the fragmentation has to
happen first before then we can get
vertical integration or is it likely to
happen forget if it has to but is it
likely I mean I think we're what we're
gonna learn is like smart contracts
might have their own protocol and the
way that people use those smart con I'm
sorry not their own protocol like
aetherium might have a bunch of
different smart contracts layers augur
is specifically for prediction markets
so gambling and is a great use case
global gambling is like why crypto I
want to be able to bet a million dollars
against someone who's in Africa like you
couldn't do that today like you could
not figure out I love how like the elite
call professional gambling investing no
this is still gambling right like if you
really think about it I mean look if you
buy that building you were taking a
probability bet that it'll make money
off more time and value will be going
into that after you buy that's still
gambling right so my gambling yeah it's
just less risky we claim yeah unless
you're buying a 2007 you can have a hand
in the outcome but you in gambling you
probably have a hand in the outcome so
most of the time unless it's literally
just craps or you know well you can
still you can learn the game you can
learn the odds so I think gambling is
gonna be good first use case cuz it was
a good first use case with Bitcoin like
here's a fantastic use case like there
were there are still Bitcoin related
casinos built on the internet that are
not supposed to be accessed by the US
but people VPN in and then a gamble yeah
somebody on the live streams from VPN
I can't my sling I can neither confirm
nor deny whether and
I have done it okay uh but in general
that I think that also by the way my
interface concept completely relates to
Columbus Columbus is an interface that
interacted originally just with Bitcoin
which is built on the blockchain like I
think there is a separation but they are
the same they are in very so tightly and
does the most value accrue to the
protocol to the DAP or to the interface
so I think personally so I do think the
protocol generates value like it's going
to generate a lot of money it's gonna be
a big deal you will make money if you
hold that protocol however I believe
that the closest to the consumer makes
the most money okay so the farther you
get away from the farther you get away
the less money you make the farther you
get away from the consumer sense money
you make yes or another way to think
about it is if there are multiple layers
stacked on top of the protocol the
farther you get away from the protocol
the money you'll make yes so the farther
away from the Progresso mike and it's
actually a little contrarian in the
market is like I I think that the the UI
ends up being the winner but it might
get super fragmented so you might be
able there gonna be a thousand you eyes
that are augur on top of aetherium well
yeah it could be a thousand so so that
are used for different things like will
vertical eyes and yeah ways I definitely
agree with you and I think that owning
equity in those companies is gonna be
way more valuable than owning tokens
over a long period of time especially
because there is a there's a higher
probability than not that the most
important protocols are already built
now which ones are they is a whole other
so i i'm certain i always think
disruption can happen but i am certain
that the ones that builders are building
on it's the stuff that's there like
people just want to build and so like
aetherium is being used and built on you
know Bitcoin is being used and built on
like people are trying the things that
are tried-and-true because the markets
they're like they don't want to build an
app on something that doesn't
have any velocity yep like if there's no
velocity like why I agree with that
what's the one thing that you would
change in crypto if you could I would
say other than own more Bitcoin yeah I
would I would stack that up the one
thing I would change is not the
speculation I actually think the
speculation did a service to the market
agreed I would change I want people to
see the actual value though like I think
it would just be like better education
that's what I would say is like I think
people went in because they saw money
and they know they're supposed to make
money like that's a thing in humans like
you have supposed to make money
so let's there's money there let's go to
it I would much rather people be
building towards like their own personal
mission and if crypto overlaps with it
they build with that so I it's an
education thing rather than I think
there's so little good education and it
does take time and buying crypto helps
where you have skin in the game like to
educate yourself on it but I would love
just better financial education as well
as in crypto it helps you understand how
incentives work and then it helps you
understand like at the at the end of the
day it makes better services and so like
it almost says nothing if I could change
one thing I want the words blockchain
crypto and Bitcoin to go away and I want
people to be using them yeah I
completely agree look we talked about a
lot we're moving to a digital world you
need digitally native assets you need
usually native accounting you need is a
native contracts and the winners are the
gateways right now yeah by the way we
didn't just use blockchain and crypto in
any of that yeah and in a digital world
you need to be immerse yourself in it
which is virtual reality that's fair in
the ocean yeah and then you need an
ocean that has Bitcoin native population
all right rapidfire to end this thing
vente exact to go pretend to be an adult
and do other things I probably do too
well I mean well you probably had a
meeting or something I don't we've been
talking for like six hours what's the
most important company in criminal okay
well you say it again what's the most
important what's most important
most important no one who recovered so
much leg room um the most important
company in crypto is coinbase that's
usually the second most important
company I say after Facebook but why do
you say coinbase just cuz the interface
and brought so many people on yeah I
just think they legitimize this space
like I think people don't give Brian
specifically enough credit for what he
had to do and how much value he's
delivered to the market by educating
institutions by educating investors and
building a product that was the easiest
way to get in I would also say I would
also say on the other side on the
jurisdictional arbitrage side I would
say finance is really important so I
would actually third is Facebook third
my whole thing is just think about the
users whatever they give to people good
people are gonna have good bad
indifference I think it's gonna be I
think we're gonna plus people I think
you're gonna be pleasantly surprised
yeah completely agree by the Facebook
token devious be decentralized I mean
yes like I think that they will have
steps towards decentralization right
that's what my guess would be I would
guess okay so in a way I would say that
it's gonna be more decentralized than
people are anticipate yeah I bet I
believe that ice is there true this is
David Marcus's mission he wants this to
exist and he's true about it I do think
that Facebook wouldn't build something
if they're not gonna control a piece of
it like I see yes where I actually
disagree I think that they can control
one of the infrastructure and interfaces
and stuff so they're thinking with the
actual donor and see it so it could be
the glue that sort of interacts with
every manner they would they would have
they would single-handedly be the
biggest nation on the planet that has
their own native likely look I worked at
the company I'm biased I throw it all
out there right but the one thing that I
know about that group of people they're
not playing for second place
yeah right like that like they're gonna
go try change the world and do some like
just epics well you're saying we're
building a digital world like we could
argue that Facebook already did build it
and that there is no native currency
there yet
now there is one and so I mean I also
you know I also think Twitter's gonna
play a big role like I mean it does kill
me as far as communicating with Twitter
people like you like it crypto people
and he's made it he's openly made just
incredible moves towards making more
leaders of the world excited about
Bitcoin
look we're not Jack made Bitcoin cool
yeah when I go to these meetings with
you will you do this too but in
endowments foundations institutions like
it's no longer like should we or I'm not
investing in crypto it was default no
yeah we're really only time now it's I'm
going to how am i understanding it yep
and they their questions are much more
around like how should we allocate not
so it's smart it's good questions it's
not about how it works anymore
yep and they have a infection in every
group like there's one the virus the
virus has spread of virus the virus
infected like somebody and they're just
obsessive about it
yeah every single group the the we
should go and pitch institutions
together and like just go dress like
this and yeah he's so smart he's so
smart so I've learned this can be one of
my last lines if you want it to be but
I've learned that there are two types of
people in this world okay the people who
accept the person who wears orange pants
and the people who do not and that's
there and that's on them and so it's
like you know I'm just being as me as
possible in the meetings yeah and I'm
not just people who ever people like is
there like a visceral reaction to orange
pants no it's just always like is this
person taking it seriously enough and so
Lane there's a little bit of an uphill
battle explaining myself sometimes but
like in general it's more you know you
well the first question they always ask
is how many pairs do have yeah and how
many will - - how many days have been
wearing this pair four in a row four in
a row that's not that bad there's no
trip to New York yeah like sometimes
that were the same socks like seven days
in or whatever yeah well if it's me
I thought you're just gonna roll with
that out of every burger action warm on
one time like actually I don't know why
I'm that way about soccer I really don't
want to wear can't wear socks two days
in a row they get a little cancer fine
whatever
even teacher so it would be a little bit
I go into my when my dirty laundry is
like overwhelming
I'll go into the dirty socks and like
pick them out if I'm out of so yeah just
you have cleaner dirty socks on right
now these are clean
yeah I only packed clean socks
all right what's the most important book
you've ever read so depends on stage of
my life I would say overall I reread
Harry Potter and I think it just it
captures the imagination in a way one of
my biggest fears is that people's
imaginations are dying and I one of the
vehicles I used to try to change that is
through investing in companies that are
going crazy and doing things and then on
the out so Harry Potter and then on the
other side I think essentialism came in
at a perfect time for me personally
where I was becoming very overwhelmed
with a lot of different things family
and work and the and it helped me just
focus on the right things at the right
time so I would say those are the two
that are on the top of my head that like
as far as impact on my life
those two are aliens real I I've so many
thoughts that you're asking me like the
deep questions now we got five minutes
first jobs real and then you could ask
me a question that weird first up if we
go to a planet we are aliens
okay so aliens are real yeah we go to a
planet yeah but do you count the moon as
a planet no it's a what are the the the
so my my answer is I'd like to believe
did you see this story that like there
was a they feel that there was no
spaceship oh yeah yeah
it's a Harvard professor a Harvard
professor whose real spaceship I need to
get I need a a lien expert to come on
and debunk my beliefs or prove them
correct because I'm at the
pointing out where your full alien I
mean look that again you can go to math
argument just be like come on but I mean
you talk to crypto people listen do not
believe in alien one of the craziest
thing that I've read about space cuz
never once sends me the space stuff like
oh this guy's weird like he read this
thing they always DM it to you from an
anonymous account by the way this is the
best brand you're gonna have the best
friend you can have is like you oh you
like crazy stuff yeah oh yeah I'm all in
on crazy which is that's my girlfriend
but the the part that no is a just blew
my mind was there's two galaxies right
now that are colliding and they can see
this or something and I actually don't
remember what happens when two galaxies
collide and they go and by the way our
galaxy is going to collide with those
two other nodes well those two other
galaxies in four billion years and I'm
like wait a minute hold on it's like the
idea of two planets colliding would be
pretty scary like if we were just like
yo Mars what's up BAM just like bumper
cars right when I was in galaxies
collide a good title to an album mono
when galaxies collide shotgun for that
band name I well I think things would be
different
yeah would be my answer so like that's
the stuff for with space it's just like
come on if there's other galaxies
colliding out there and all the stuff
there's gotta be aliens work like we we
don't know I believe that there are
aliens I I actually go back and forth on
parallel universes too but like I I
don't know where are you I don't need it
to confess like how incredibly weird I
am on this I don't think I'm just going
to change the name of the podcast the
weirdos iasts yeah okay good yeah
Russell wrong weirdoes
what one question do you have for me
[Music]
okay what is the biggest adventure you
have ever been on the biggest adventure
in 2015 on 12 hours notice I booked a
flight to Midian Columbia
myself I went landed didn't know where I
was staying
got an Airbnb who said to the host like
hey man listener to do around here I
read that this is one of the like top 25
up-and-coming destinations and it's like
there was arbitrage between everyone
thought it was super unsafe because of
all like the deco stuff all stuff but it
actually was like one of the safest
places now cuz they've really cleaned it
up and he was like oh there's a bunch of
things to do but whatever and one of
those things was to go see what is his
name
not El Chapo the the Norris Geyser ghost
yeah yeah what is its name his name it's
called hacienda nápoles is uh is the
name of the place and Pablo Pablo Pablo
us more yeah thank you the Internet I
knew the Pablo Escobar so you can go to
Pablo Escobar's compound it's like an
hour and a half two hours I'd take this
bus then you kind of walk up there and
it was wild because like you're
literally in the backwoods of Colombia
walking around Pablo Escobar's thing and
there is a federal prison that they have
built and literally the people are in
cage like fenced cages and you can see
them and I just never being like
standing there a moment he's been like
whoa where what did I do like how did I
get here
those are the best wandering the wander
yeah and I just remember like he was
just every day for like a week I just
woke up like what I wanna do today BAM
you sweatin did it and it was a lot of
fun and so since then that led to I've
done a bunch of these now like I went to
Israel so it sparked you to yeah I will
do this more my brother and I went to
India for two weeks and just do things
like hey man you like let's stop taking
new burgers like you guys run
motorcycles he's like I never driven one
before and so we rented motorcycles in
this busy Indianness village or city
gosh and he's driving traffic is
unbelievable first time he ever drove a
motorcycle so stuff like that is just
like look it's just like you're charging
your own life like either gonna get the
[ __ ] done or you're not and my gonna
have some fun along the way so
they ready I'm gonna leave you with a
quote I've had pac-man Pat McNamara went
on Joe Rogan's podcast recently yeah and
I heard this quote it's just seared in
my brain okay he hit him with every
night is Saturday night every morning is
Monday morning I was like man what a
legendary life motto to live by well
this is Anthony Bourdain my my body is a
carnival or something like that like
like just live life to the fullest yeah
just do whatever you want all right man
this is a absolute pleasure I had a fun
had a fun time I can't even talk
anywhere we've talked so much we talked
a lot I did not realize over an hour and
37 minutes were we supposed to know less
no we're supposed to just go until you
get tired of talking you have a lot of
text messages by the way all right we're
gonna stop recording well I just I just
I just yeah well I'm only like 30
minutes late for my next thing this is
great thank you everyone for tuning in